[Música]
máxima expectativa en eeuu en dónde
avanza el conteo de los votos en
condados y estados clave para determinar
quién será el presidente de eeuu by den
conquisto wisconsin michigan y acumula
ya 264 votos electorales mientras que
trump lidera el conteo que avanza en
pensilvania y en georgia
ya esta hora también toma fuerza a
manifestaciones pacíficas en el centro
de la ciudad de washington es de
seguidores tanto de joe biden como de
donald trump quienes se muestran
optimistas ante el triunfo de uno de los
dos candidatos y piden rapidez en el
conteo de los votos tenemos los detalles
desde la capital estadounidense
y también en el senado ambos partidos
disputan muy de cerca cada escaño no son
republicanos tienen ya 48 mientras que
los demócratas tienen 47 mientras que la
cámara de representantes toma la
delantera allí el partido republicano
que en la legislación anterior tenía
mayoría
[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora vamos a comenzar en eeuu allí como
lo hemos venido diciendo a lo largo de
la jornada avanza el conteo de los votos
en algunos condados y también en algunos
estados para determinar quién será el
nuevo presidente de ese país aún se
mantiene en suspenso los resultados en
algunos estados como alaska nevada
georgia carolina del norte y
pennsylvania hasta el momento el
candidato demócrata joe biden lidera el
número de votos electorales con 264
votos asignados mientras que el
presidente aspirante a la reelección por
el partido republicano donald trump como
ya lo decía el partido republicano tiene
214 votos del colegio electoral esto
mientras continúa el conteo de los votos
en varios condados y en estados
cruciales
por su parte desde wilmington en el
estado de delaware el candidato
demócrata joe biden reiteró hoy su
llamado a la prudencia y su confianza en
el sistema electoral estadounidense
mientras avanza el conteo de los votos y
también se mostró confiado en que de
continuar la tendencia que se ha
presentado hasta ahora podría llegar a
los 270 votos electorales que necesita
para llegar a la casa blanca también
hizo un llamado a la unión del país
estas fueron sus palabras
es claro que estamos ganando en
suficientes estados 270 votos electores
para ganar a la presidencia yo estoy
aquí para declarar que ganamos estoy
aquí para reportar cuando la cuenta esté
finalizada de que creemos que seremos
los ganadores oscar con todos los votos
contados hemos ganado wisconsin
por 220 mil votos virtualmente el mismo
margen que el presidente tropo obtuvo en
ese estado hace cuatro años ya su turno
el presidente y candidato republicano
donald trump opinó sobre el conteo de
los votos y también sobre sus reclamos
al sistema electoral y lo hizo como
mejor lo sabe hacer a través de la red
social 'twitter'
esto fue lo que dijo el mandatario
nuestros abogados pidieron acceso total
pero que de bueno hace esto el daño ya
está hecho a la integridad de nuestro
sistema y a la elección presidencial
esto es lo que debería discutirse
y en el centro de la ciudad de
washington tantos seguidores del
presidente de donald trump como del
candidato joe biden se han dado cita
allí para mostrar su apoyo a ambos
candidatos ambos grupos se muestran muy
optimistas en cuanto al triunfo de
alguno de los dos
diana castañeda la corresponsal de
france 24 en la capital estadounidense
estuvo con ellos más temprano y nos da
más detalles de lo que sucede allí
en esta plaza en el centro de washington
es conocida como mcpherson square desde
la noche de ayer se han dado cita
seguidores de job airén para seguir
minuto a minuto los resultados de estos
comicios electorales hablamos con
algunos de los seguidores del candidato
demócrata
[Música]
i
y los resultados más positivos nosotros
vamos a estar haciendo presencia en las
calles hasta que cada voto sea contado
es mejor que se den su tiempo para
contar el voto correctamente a hacer
algo curado estamos de acuerdo que todo
voto tiene que ser contado que es una de
las razones por la que estamos acá todos
nosotros y si se toma un par de días más
pues que se lo tomen todo que cuente
cada voto
muchos de los seguidores de baire en que
se encuentran acá dicen estar
cautelosamente optimistas ante los
resultados y también en la manera en
cómo se ha dado estos comicios
electorales
es muy difícil encontrar seguidores del
presidente donde actúan más que la
capital de los eeuu ya que el 90% de los
residentes están registrados como
demócratas pero le preguntamos a una
seguidora de donaldson que se en saba de
cómo se han realizado estos soluciones
smart power y el pienso y no es una
opinión que le guste a la gente pero
creo que trump ganó mayoritariamente y
que el cómic fue una trampa para que la
gente mandará sus votos por correo y
ahora de la nada hay más de 300.000
votos en una noche y que trump ganó pero
están robando las elecciones fire and
nature tendencial del action
mientras tanto la seguridad continúa
siendo reforzada cerca de la casa blanca
y todo el área del centro de washington
dc está bloqueado porque el servicio
secreto y la policía metropolitana están
cautelosos ante la posibilidad de que
seguidores ya sea de uno o del otro el
candidato que está buscando la
presidencia lleguen a darse cita acá
para manifestarse
y está con nosotros en el estudio de
france 24 rafael piñero con quien vamos
a analizar este tema de las elecciones y
cómo avanza el conteo rafael gracias por
estar de nuevo aquí con nosotros y
quiero que hagamos lupa en dos estados
que están allí avanzando el conteo de
las papeletas y cualquier voto puede ser
decisivo georgia y pensilvania cómo está
el panorama de la situación en georgia
hay que entenderla a partir de los
cientos urbanos más grandes
atlante y sus suburbios aún tienen
muchos votos que contar lo mismo que la
ciudad de augusta y en menor media
columbus esos tres centros van a ser
neurálgicos para determinar si el
candidato joe biden tiene la posibilidad
de rebasar lo que ha hecho de manera muy
positiva el presidente donald trump ha
venido incrementando su participación en
ese estado y por el otro lado el estado
de pensilvania es un estado histórico y
fundamental es el históricamente es
importante por la industria siderúrgica
por la industria petrolera y en los
últimos años despunta con mucha fuerza
el fracking de tal forma que el discurso
basada
en una revolución energética de you by
the end en ocasiones no sentaba muy bien
asimismo hay que tener en cuenta que
cuando el presidente
donald trump se retiró del tratado de
parís fue a la ciudad de pittsburgh
emblemática por la industria del acero y
dijo es por ustedes es por los trabajos
que se están perdiendo respecto a china
que he decidido sacar a los eeuu de ese
importante acuerdo medioambiental
entonces ha hecho que en los últimos
años los demócratas que habían ganado
hasta el 2016 seis elecciones
consecutivas en el estado de pensilvania
hayan perdido esa importante plaza
hillary lo hizo particularmente mal hace
cuatro años disminuyó la votación total
que había tenido anteriormente barack
obama en el estado y ha confiado en el
presidente demócrata pero con hillary
clinton en esa situación cambió
dramáticamente ha cambiado también la
composición hasta hace aproximadamente
20 o 25 años eran trabajadores
sindicalizados unión izados y la
transformación económica que ha vivido
ha hecho que en los últimos años pierdan
mucho peso el trabajo
es decir esa persona que no tiene título
universitario pero que sin duda alguna
era importante en el entorno los centros
más importantes ya los hemos mencionado
en filadelfia pittsburgh en menor medida
scranton donde nació el candidato yo vi
que hay del estado de nevada que está
completamente blindado en este momento
no tenemos ningún dato de una posible
proyección contaron unos votos hasta un
punto dieron a conocer hasta un punto
los resultados y la autoridad electoral
allí dijo no vamos a dar sino un
resultado final en las próximas 24 horas
y allí hay una proyección y es difícil
saber que puede decir entonces nevada en
esta elección en las últimas elecciones
también ha favorecido al partido
demócrata los centros más los centros
urbanos más importantes son los que van
a determinar la contienda y el
porcentaje escrutado todavía da un
margen de maniobra para que
eventualmente un muy buen resultado del
candidato del presidente donald trump
acercara y pusiera más difícil la
balanza en ese estado sin embargo la
tendencia por la influencia de
california es que sé
favorecido por favor mejor del partido
demócrata con lo cual yo vaivén llegaría
al mágico número de 270 del cual hemos
hablado que tendría la posibilidad de
conformar el colegio electoral sin
embargo también es cierto que debido a
la impugnación especialmente en los
estados del norte puede que sea difícil
de determinar con precisión en este
momento cuál sea el rumbo que va a tomar
la elección del estado claro entonces
para yo vaivenes nevada en este momento
en este momento sin momento lo es
muchas gracias rafael por este análisis
para nuestra audiencia aquí en france 24
además de la elección presidencial
también está en disputa 470 sillas en el
congreso estadounidense de ellas 35
corresponden a la renovación parcial del
senado y 435 a la cámara de
representantes en la cámara de
representantes hasta el momento 203
sillas son para el partido demócrata que
retendría de esta manera la mayoría que
ostentaba en la legislatura pasada y 188
sillas son para los republicanos en
cuanto al senado el período pasado
estuvo nominado por
los republicanos y en este momento
registran 47 sillas para los demócratas
y 48 para los republicanos aún hay 5
sillas que están a la espera de ser
asignadas a algunos de los dos partidos
y el estado de pensilvania como ya lo
decíamos se ha convertido en el centro
de la tormenta política en esta puja por
el voto electoral entre los dos
candidatos el mar y ángulo de la
redacción de france 24 nos explica la
importancia que tiene este estado para
los comicios
pensilvania otorga 20 votos electorales
lo que equivale a la mayor cantidad que
aún queda por definir
así las cosas y throne gana en este
estado aseguraría la reelección en medio
de la incertidumbre los habitantes se
muestran divididos pero confiados en que
la decisión final no genere hechos
violentos en su territorio
no creo que aquí haya violencia en todo
eeuu creo que podría haberla ya sabes
hemos tenido muchos disturbios y esas
cosas y creo que podríamos ver eso pero
no por aquí no lo creo
los ancianos
es el día después de las elecciones y
ahora tenemos que esperar 4 días para
saber quién ganó eso es absolutamente
absurdo va a hacer lo que necesite para
llenar sus propios bolsillos y los
bolsillos de la gente que está moviendo
los hilos dice muchas cosas para la
gente pero honestamente que ha hecho en
los últimos cuatro años nada
de acuerdo con lo indicado por el
gobernador de este estado demócrata tom
wolfe todavía restan por ser contados
más de un millón de votos por correo por
lo que los señalamientos de trump sobre
el presunto fraude serían solo parte de
un ataque partidista con 12 millones 700
mil habitantes pensilvania es el sexto
estado más poblado del país uno en el
que a diferencia de otros como georgia
los votos por correo no fueron
procesados con antelación por lo que
trump afirma que las papeletas contadas
desde el cierre de las urnas serían
fraudulentas
y el tema de las elecciones en estados
unidos siguen siendo tendencia en las
redes sociales hay múltiples reacciones
en torno a lo que ha sucedido en el país
norteamericano sobre los resultados los
reclamos que ha hecho el presidente de
donald trump y también sobre el
desempeño electoral de joe biden vamos a
dar paso a andrés meza muñoz ante la
redacción de france 24 para tomar el
pulso a las redes sociales andrés buenas
noches adelante que se dice en las redes
sociales
buenas noches santiago como usted lo ha
dicho son las redes sociales el
escenario de estas constantes reacciones
mientras avanza el conteo de votos
vamos a ver precisamente el tuit del
presidente de donald trump que emitimos
hace un momento acerca de esta contienda
y dicen nuestros abogados han pedido un
acceso significativo pero de qué sirve
esto el daño ya se ha hecho a la
integridad de nuestro sistema y a la
propia elección presidencial esto es lo
que debería discutirse dice el
mandatario a medida que pide un recuento
en wisconsin que no se cuenten más votos
en michigan y que no se reciban más
papeletas en pensilvania uno de los más
incendiarios ha sido el hijo del
presidente donantes eric trump quien
dijo hemos ganado en pencil
sin embargo ahí como lo vemos en
pantalla tweeter agregó un verificador
de contenido que dice que es posible que
las fuentes oficiales no hayan anunciado
los resultados cuando se tuiteó esto y
precisamente de pensilvania sigue bajo
escrutinio twitter y facebook han estado
escondiendo o instalando verificadores
de contenido a trome a su equipo que
tratan de deslegitimar la elección y
esto como parte de su política para
combatir la desinformación veamos ahora
las reacciones de la fórmula
vicepresidencial de joe biden kamala
harris quien junto a yo bailén han
estado muy activos en redes sociales
respondiendo a los comentarios de trump
dijo anoche toma amenazó con ir a la
corte para evitar que se contarán todos
los votos pero nuestra campaña está
preparada para contra atacar sin embargo
el presidente el vicepresidente de mike
pence sólo se ha limitado a replicar
información con pedagogía electoral
organizaciones verificadores de hecho
como sucede
como política organizado verificando
estos hechos para combatir la
desinformación
muchas gracias a andrés por este reporte
en cuanto a lo que sucede en las redes
sociales a ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía
e informándolos en france24 buenas
noches
[Música]